are we and of course Rishi sooner gave
me a past that threshold all-important
threshold of a hundred nominations at
from MPS but the only remaining
Contender given that Boris Johnson has
not thrown his hat into the ring at
Penny modern well she's certainly got
some catching up to do one of those in
her Corner sir Roger Gale joined us on
the program so Roger a very good morning
to you um let's start shall we if we can
with with Boris Johnson not as mentioned
at throwing his hat into the ring was
there an inevitability about that Good
Morning Neil yes I think there was uh
there was a harsh difference of reality
between the beaches of Dominica and uh
the atmosphere in Westminster and I
think Mr Johnson came back discovered
that he did not have the overwhelming
support of the Parliamentary party never
mind people in the country
and made the right decision for himself
for his country
and of course for the conservative party
given that Penny Warden has this morning
been been praising Boris Johnson on
Twitter for doing the honorable thing
for putting country ahead of personal
priorities putting country ahead of
party and stepping aside given where
she's at in terms of the numbers is now
not perhaps the point that Penny mordant
considers her own position
where she's at in terms of the numbers
is not I think quite um where with
respect reports are saying
um I saw a penny where are they then sir
Roger
a beg your button go and tell me where
are the numbers how many has she gone
I'm not privy to that information but I
Saw Penny about 20 minutes ago and she
said we're in the zone and look Neil I
think what is important is that we do
have the choice put before members of
parliament and then before the country
I'm fairly relaxed about this well not
before the country sir Roger before the
conservative party membership the two
are really different but before the all
right fine before the conservative party
membership in the country but we've got
a team of people now penny mordant
um Jeremy Hunt has the chance of the
exchequer Ben Wallace who is Prosecuting
a war in Ukraine and Rishi sunak who is
indubitably talented and I think between
them in whatever order those four people
will unite our party the country and
take us forward to where we need to be
and that is what really matters in the
National interest
so what then in your view would be lost
by this being a Rishi sunak coronation
without the membership being given the
opportunity to have their say I'm not a
great fan of coronations they uh well
not political correlations they tend to
unravel and I think it is important that
the Parliamentary party has a choice and
that the membership of the country as
you've so rightly corrected me has a has
a choice whatever that choice is I will
and I'm sure that the overwhelming
majority
of the Parliamentary party and party
members will rally behind whoever
emerges as the leader because that's
what we've got to do but penny is a
great team player and a great team
leader and that's really why I'm
supporting her she's got immense
capacity to bring people together
indeed but perhaps given the way in
which the membership viewed Rishi
sunak's last attempt to become a leader
of the party presumably I'm taking from
what you're saying you don't feel that
he would be capable of uniting the party
I'd like the membership to have a
straightforward choice between two
people Penny Morton and Rishi sunak and
I would hope and expect
that not only I
um but all the members and I've been a
member of the party for before since
before Boris Johnson was born actually
um I think I would hope and expect that
we will all rally behind whoever emerges
as the leader because we've got a job of
work to do and that's what matters what
matters is is the people of this country
it's real people's real lives is
mortgages his interest rates is the cost
of living those are the things we've got
to deal with
but but that has that has been the case
since the start of the last leadership
contest I mean I put a similar question
to Grant chaps a little earlier but what
has been the point of this conservative
government for the past three months
I think we've come very seriously off
the rails in the last three months we
have to get back on track Jeremy Hunters
made a very good start in repairing some
of the damage that has been done there's
a heck of a lot more work to do quite
clearly and we needed the right team of
people to do that and the right team
leader to lead the team but it can be
done and I have every confidence that it
will be done
what happened in that meeting between
Penny Morton and Boris Johnson I mean
did she offer him something to get him
to step aside to give her perhaps some
of her some of his nominations
I I was not a fly on the wall in that
meeting any more than you were Nile and
I don't know but knowing penny
who is very straight talking indeed I
think she will have simply said I'm
sorry that is not a game that I am
prepared to play
um that negotiation was never really a
starter but as courtesy she took the
call
tell me then why you believe so firmly
that that penny more than who does not
have an overwhelming CV in terms of uh
in terms of a party experience
experience in high office why you feel
that penny more than should be the next
prime minister I think that's if I may
say so more than a little unfair she's
held nine ministerial posts she was
Secretary of State for overseas
development which requires considerable
degree of empathy and and understanding
she was then Secretary of State for
defense which is no mean task in itself
as the president of the privy Council
she showed great Dignity of following
the death of her majesty at the
accession council and managed that I
think superbly she's handled her role as
leader of the House very well indeed he
stood in for the Prime Minister on a
rather Sticky Wicket last week and
demonstrated how she is capable of
managing the house managing business and
bringing people together I think that's
interesting under a bus by saying that
she wasn't hiding under a desk no I
don't think she did at all I know the
Press made a great deal of that but she
simply threw back at Stella Creasy what
Stella Creasy threw at her
and and just a final thought from you
sir Roger genuinely I mean with your
experience do you think that the
conservative party can come back from
this given the absolute paroxysms it's
been in for the past three months yes I
do absolutely and I am heartily relieved
Neil that uh I can now say with total
confidence and honesty I will support
whoever emerges as the leader and I
couldn't have said that 24 hours ago
so Roger always a pleasure to talk to
you thanks very much for joining us at
this morning on breakfast